Hier will einfach jeder hoch, der nach
Eisenach kommt:
zur Wartburg.
Für viele Deutsche ist sie mehr als nur
irgendeine Burg aus dem 11. Jahrhundert.
Sie ist Sehenswürdigkeit und
nationaler Mythos zugleich.
Und das liegt vor allem an einem Mann:
Martin Luther.
Ab 1521, vier Jahre nachdem er
seine Thesen veröffentlicht hatte,
übersetzte er hier das Neue Testament
ins Deutsche – eine Revolution.
Denn jeder Deutsche, der lesen konnte,
hatte jetzt darauf Zugriff.
Luther war nicht der erste,
der die Bibel übersetzt hat,
aber er hat sie sehr gut übersetzt.
Und er hat sie vor allem aus dem Urtext,
aus dem Griechischen, übersetzt und
nicht bloß das
Lateinische ins Deutsche übertragen.
Eine Sonderausstellung zum
Reformationsjubiläum erinnert derzeit
auf der Wartburg an Martin Luther.
Mehr als 300 Exponate zeigen,
wie sich die Sicht auf ihn
in den vergangenen 500 Jahren immer
wieder verändert hat:
Luther, der Nationalheld.
Luther, der Kirchenspalter.
Eine oft umstrittene historische Figur.
Die Ausstellung auf der Wartburg
zeigt 500 Jahre deutsche Geschichte
und zwar immer unter dem Blickwinkel
‚Luther und die Deutschen‘.
Wie hat die Reformation die deutsche
Geschichte beeinflusst, aber auch,
wie hat jede historische Epoche
ein eigenes Lutherbild hervorgebracht?
Immer wieder war die Wartburg
Schauplatz deutscher Geschichte.
Viele prächtige Säle zeugen davon:
zum Beispiel die Kemenate der
Heiligen Elisabeth von Thüringen,
die im 13. Jahrhundert auf der Burg lebte –
oder der Sängersaal, wo im Mittelalter
angeblich ein legendärer
Gesangswettbewerb stattfand.
Und 1817 trafen sich hier rund 500
Studenten, die die Einheit der damals
zersplitterten deutschen Nation forderten.
Unterhalb der Wartburg liegt die Stadt
Eisenach.
Das Lutherhaus – hier lebte der
Reformator als Schüler.
Martin Luther begegnet einem im Ort
auf Schritt und Tritt –
die Georgenkirche, in der er predigte.
In diesem Haus wurde 1685 eine andere
große Persönlichkeit Eisenachs geboren:
der Komponist Johann Sebastian Bach.
Das Museum zeigt, was Luther und Bach
gemeinsam haben.
Im 20. Jahrhundert verbanden viele
DDR-Bürger Eisenach vor allem mit ihm:
dem DDR-Kultauto "Wartburg", benannt
nach dem Wahrzeichen der Stadt.
Der "353er" wurde mehr als 20 Jahre
hier gebaut und hat bis heute Fans –
wie Marko Röhler, der seinen dreißig
Jahre alten Wartburg hegt und pflegt –
und natürlich auch fährt.
Der Wartburg bedeutet für mich Tradition
der Automobilgeschichte von Eisenach,
starke Verbundenheit
und Heimatgefühl auch.
Weil ich mit dieser Stadt, mit diesem Auto,
mit diesem Werk aufgewachsen bin.
Seit mehr als 120 Jahren werden in
Eisenach ununterbrochen Autos gebaut.
Heute hat Opel hier eine Fabrik.
Touristen können die Wagen in der
"automobile welt" sehen –
natürlich auch den Wartburg.
Es war eben auch das Besondere,
dass die Autos denselben Namen hatten
wie die Burg und die unmittelbare
Verbindung Eisenach-Wartburg.
Man stand ... Das Auto stand gleichzeitig
eben auch für die
facettenreiche Vielfältigkeit dieser
Stadt, die eine Kulturstadt ist
und eine Industriestadt. Das war ja nie
ein Widerspruch.
Ich sag einfach: Die Leute haben so
einen Schluck Benzin im Blut.
Und ein Herz für Deftiges:
Abschließen kann man die Eisenach-Tour
mit den typischen Thüringer Klößen,
wie hier im Haus Hainstein.
Hergestellt werden sie aus zwei Dritteln
rohen und einem Drittel
gekochter Kartoffeln – und
einem Croûton in der Mitte.
In heißem Wasser sieden sie so lange,
bis sie an die Oberfläche kommen.
Der Spitzname der Thüringer Klöße
heißen [ist] ‚Hütjes‘.
[Das] stammt daher, weil jede Familie
ihr eigenes Kloßrezept hütet.
Und deswegen: Hüte es, ‚Hütjes‘.
Und da hat jede Familie ihre Eigenarten
wie sie noch diese Klöße
oder diese Masse verfeinern.
Einige heben noch Kondensmilch drunter,
einige heben noch Crème fraîche drunter.
Serviert werden sie mit
Rouladen und Rotkohl.
Und natürlich einer Flasche Luther-Wein.
Das ist ja klar in Eisenach, der
Luther-Stadt am Fuße der Wartburg.